in the UK a prominent Conservative Party
politicians under fire after he made a
joking reference to Libyan Jacob Riis
MOG called the African state the
People's Republic of jam jar or
something as he put it at the
Conservative Party's annual conference
this is quite a bizarre comment to be
heard from a well-known politician
referencing an another nation this was
indeed hardline brexit ear and Tory MP
Jacob Riis MOG speaking on the sidelines
of the annual Conservative Party
conference and what he was actually
referencing was the great socialist
people's Libyan Arab Jamahiriya which is
roughly translated as a state of masses
and that's what the North African nation
of Libya used to be called under Muammar
Qaddafi yet he chose those words instead
and reaction was very Swift to follow
Deary me Jacob Riis mug your first
attempt at global diplomacy has failed
an abyss of casual racism
did you and Boris Johnson have the same
geography teacher at Eton College maybe
now is the time to learn some respect
for other countries little Englander
jacob riis MOG shows his disdain for the
rest of the world this tawdry Tory
government has had its time Britain
deserves better than this inward-looking
bunch of unworldly has-beens and never
worse this sort of remark is becoming
too common from the brexit ears coming
as it does in the wake of Boris's recent
burqa jibes insulting other people is
not the way I want my country
represented and the public see it for
what it is petty politics the reason
those Boris Johnson burka jives and
Boris Johnson in general get mentioned
in a few of those reactions is because
former UK Foreign Secretary has himself
come under fire on many occasions for
quite controversial comments with the
burkas he had just recently compared
women wearing them to letter boxes
causing quite a bit of controversy here
in the UK but with these latest comments
on Libya they do seem quite
strange indeed especially given the rule
that britain had played in the destiny
of libya as a nation Arab writer and
journalist Abdul Bari at one believes
this kind of language can be heard all
through British politics and society
themselves ashamed of themselves because
actually they interfered by by military
means to destroy countries under false
accusation and they use this which we
discover it is a pure lie and then we
repeat the same thing and attack Libya
change a regime there and let the
country is completely an arcane this is
the problem of British people sorry
british politician they should be
ashamed of themselves we should actually
realize that the separate country
African countries are aware of what is
happening in the world and they don't
believe all the talks about democracy or
about human rights
you